hello
this is about collaboration this is our
film we couldn't make it without
you
and you believe it we could make it
without him
i'm but we're not we're not making it
hi everybody
we want we want basically to make a
movie where everybody in the world can
be a part of it
so it's a dollar or more to get your
name in the credit says holla
and holla does these are the paintings
that create the one second of animation
they're all done during this big party
and a couple of people came and people
at the party helped do the paintings
executive producer
i'm not messing around
you're gonna get a full set of business
cards and a t-shirt
hey brooke please please tell me what
you're doing right now becoming a
criminal and a producer on the one
second film
brooke how do you feel about jail i
can't wait for the food you know they
treat producers better in jail so
it's true
oh it died of silent death
it will live on yay good job and good
luck
on your oh you know you should really
make that r
one oh yeah that's right
right there this is your yeah our
hour thank you and good luck on our one
second phone
so many times